John Bradley was here and and and we
were talking to him about his experience
at the the party the sort of you know
premiere party for the final season and
he said that a big moment for him was
getting to meet Dave Chappelle and
realizing Dave Chappelle is a fan and I
bet for a lot of different people in
Game of Thrones different cast members
there's certain people you meet who were
fans and it really means something to
you that that person's a fan do you know
I mean like oh my god that person's a
fan that I idolized that person well I
can remember on set this year I was this
is quite nerdy
this isn't like Dave Chappelle but I was
well there's no nerdy stuff on this no
but Amy and I hear jocks beat em up Andy
[Laughter]
but yeah I was reading a book by this
neuroscientist called David Eagleman and
then our producers just warp I went huh
you were in needleman's book you know
this guy and then he took a picture of
me and sent it to this incredible
scientist so the craziest show no this
neurosis yeah are you yeah are you
studying to be a nurse I am going back
and sometimes get study news right yeah
that's fantastic are you gonna still do
some acting as well do you think you're
gonna try and split your time between
neuroscience and acting yeah definitely
that for you I love that yeah it just
feels like especially after the end of
this sort of wild 10 years which kind of
feels like I've already lived an entire
life and career already and I'm just
it's actually like I've only just turned
20 yeah you when this started beginning
my life when this started you were 10
you're 20 now so this really has been
and and those are formative years in
your life you know I don't count the
first couple because none of us well 1
through 5 nothing's going on yeah you
know it's genuinely quite hard to
remember what life was like before Game
of Thrones you know it was as you said
it was that kind of age where you you
haven't really even become the person
you are yet kind of everything about me
today
is in some way some way I owe it to Game
of Thrones and it's imagined profoundly
emotional yeah to that I know that you
guys all finished you you wrapped on
this show over a year ago yeah nearly
nearly a year ago and so you've lived
for a while knowing that ok we're no
longer shooting Game of Thrones but at
least you've known that the show isn't
over now you're sort of marching towards
the end of the show and it kind of felt
I remember after we finished filming and
we had like I had a really emotional
last day in floods of tears saying
goodbye to people who have literally
watched me grow up it is genuinely like
leaving home or saying goodbye to your
family these people have have known you
for so well and worked with you in such
close proximity and with such intensity
for such a long time and then after that
was done I was kind of like within a
couple of months it was like I'm over
this you know it's done this is history
and then of course it all starts coming
out and it death
he doesn't filled up now it's kind of
peak hysteria at the moment so I think
it won't be for another six or seven
months until it's all done and sort of
getting quiet and and everybody starts
to move on and then it will be like whoa
right where am i right
studying neuroscience which I think it's
amazing I love it you're doing a better
you than me
Game of Thrones airs Sundays at 9:00 on
HBO like we need to have our own when I
look over and they're holding up a card
tell people when Game of Thrones is on
in case they're interested anyway it's
this thing it's on 9:00 at HBO try and
find it good luck to you
Isaac Hampstead right please come back
and see us again always a pleasure
[Applause]